[Music]
[Music]
so yes my dear friends we are happy to
share the good news and that is godzilla
will be seen again in the big screen
well if you do have a big screen in your
living room that is a new godzilla
series has just been announced and it
will be focusing on all the things that
happened between godzilla 2014 and
godzilla king of the monsters this
series will be showcased in apple tv and
not on netflix like the upcoming kong
animated series so the big question now
is what will the story be like and what
titans will we be seeing in this show
stay tuned and keep watching for our
in-depth discussion and well thought out
theories for everything related to this
wonderful announcement so we might be a
little bit late for this announcement
but it's not because of slow action it's
because we are connecting the dots on
which times they are likely to be seen
or appear in the monsterverse godzilla
series we do have quite a good idea on
what will happen given that we know the
timeline between godzilla 2014 and
godzilla kotm so here's the premise of
the show
following the thunderous battle between
godzilla and the titans that level san
francisco and a shocking new reality
that monsters are real the untitled
series explores one family's journey to
uncover its buried secrets and a legacy
linking them to the secret organization
known as monarch
oh yeah legendary and touhou are besties
for now and they have renewed their
license to make more godzilla flicks in
the future it seems that this
incarnation of godzilla will not just go
away he is a fan favorite loved much
more than any other version of him since
1954 the hashtag continued the monster
verse did work and even more so than the
restore the snyder cup hashtag we now
have two interesting shows the godzilla
series in the making that will be seen
in apple tv and the animated netflix
gong series which will also focus on the
master vs titans gong and not a new king
kong made from scratch so what do we
know after reading the premise
what's in store what items will be seen
of course this is still speculation but
if it's going to be true to the most of
us timeline then let's get to it and
leave to see the titans
our idea is that we will see godzilla
series showcasing a brand new titan well
not really a brand new titan but
relatively new to the live action
screens we will see the muto prime in
action the same one from the comics
godzilla aftershock well this isn't just
a wild guess remember that they said
this will continue from the thunderous
battle between godzilla and the titans
in san francisco which means that these
statements are none other than the
murals yes my friends these beloved
kaiju will be seen again albeit in brief
screen timings uh in the beginning of
the show remember that the mutual primes
awakening and fighting with godzilla
happen immediately after the death of
the two murders which means that the
comics aftershock will be converted from
drawing on paper into cgi on screen
yeah so moving on this is a series and
not a movie so there will be a lot more
than just aftershock in here the main
question is what happened between
godzilla 2014 and king of the monsters
in the master verse when the world
became aware of the existence of titans
and the fact that there is a secret
organization that knows a lot about
these monsters and not only that but has
made significant strides in studying
them
secretly without revealing the truth to
the public well for one monarch will be
facing a tough time in general public
reviews in that show but then again we
will also be seeing this organization
being transformed into a bigger entity
with money flowing into them and with
that there's going to be the discovery
of more talents all over the world and
that my friends is the frosting over the
cake we will most likely see the titles
that weren't showcased in godzilla vs
kong and kotm but were only mentioned
and seen in the monitor screens of kotm
and they will all have their moment in
the sun in this series
so we will also follow monarch as they
discover titans all over the planet
changing the whole perception of the
human race as the masters of this world
the series as said before will focus on
a family right after godzilla 2014 and
san francisco which means only one
family that is important enough to carry
the series ahead one that faced tragedy
and has a deep connection to monarch
without even knowing their importance
and yes that would most probably be the
russell family the loss of their male
child in the battle of 2014 against
emiros and their work with the orca the
device that detects and emits
bio-acoustic signatures of the titans
and we might see them perfecting the
device well at least emma russell doing
it while mark russell goes into
depression
well if memory recalls it was emma
russell who helped godzilla in the fight
against the muter prime distracting it
with a sonic device that imitates the
biosignature of the jinchin mushi this
is of course the prototype orca and its
sound distracts the jinshin mushi the
muter prime long enough for godzilla to
get back up lift the mute prime on his
back and fire a nuclear pulse from his
damaged dorsal blades well with this
breakthrough in orca technology it will
lead monarch in the quest to find more
of these titans spreading all across the
globe finding new ones in strange
locations and even studying them and
their ancient inscriptions and learning
more about the history of the super
species and the human race so let's come
to the crux of this topic so what are
the probable talents that will be seen
with the family and monarch discovering
secrets as well as locations of new
tyrants we will most likely be seeing
the construction of containment
facilities of tyrants such as the
leviathan and scotland the monster that
inspired the legend of the loch ness
monster and we will also be seeing
others like amhulu in russia mukule
in central africa
all these states that were discovered
due to the orca device of course we
won't be seeing rodan sila and
methuselah since they are all
underground but we might be seeing
facilities built around them by monarch
since all this happened between 2014 and
2019 we might also see tiamat in live
action and also mothra hatching out from
her egg in the end of it and we might
also see monarch finally discovering
monster zero frozen under the antarctic
eyes
imagine seeing the likes of mukele and
bembe finally on tv a bunyip from
australia and even sekhmet and bafferman
these titans that till now we have no
idea what they look like seems that the
monsterverse will be showcasing unique
titan designs we do know what amherst
nakika tiamat and the others look like
but we haven't seen the others that were
only mentioned in the monitor screens in
kotm
so this will be the perfect time to
fulfill the fans wishes and milk that
cow till the last drop show us baphomet
what the goat god of the temples look
like or sekhmet the ancient deity of the
egyptians if she has the appearance of a
cat island or has the insecticide body
as seen briefly in the monitor screens
as x-ray photos we also want to see
typhon quezon coral yamato no orochi and
abedin make this dream come true
yeah so okay let's
chill out a little bit
but what if we are wrong about the
russell family and what if there's
another family following godzilla and
not the ones from kotm
well then we won't have much to theorize
about this
if this is the case a brand new family
meaning a brand new cast and characters
that will follow a giant monster to
uncover their legacy with monarch seems
like the most obvious candidates will be
the ones from skull island or maybe
sarizawa and his family coming back into
this show but this seems a little bit
far-fetched so let's take the first
theory as the most probable one but mind
you take this with a grain of salt as we
have no idea what legendary might be
hiding up their sleeves
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam